bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen à bruxelles
l'enquète de cette émission s'intéresse
à la drogue aux salles de shoot et à
leur impact en termes de salubrité
publique
reportage au luxembourg dans un refuge
pour toxicomanes mais au coeur d'une
structure sociale mais tout de suite
place à l'actualité avec cette question
le traité budgétaire européen aurait-il
mérité un référendum en france ces
derniers jours on a beaucoup défilé dans
les capitales européennes madrid athènes
paris sous les pavés la colère mais
coûterait quoi le tcg le traité sur la
stabilité la coordination et la
gouvernance
pour ses détracteurs le traité
osterrieth air à la sacro-sainte
austérité celle qui écrase la zone euro
qui vaut à son taux de chômage culminer
à un an et demi pour cent soit 18
millions de personnes dans les cortèges
des portraits de françois hollande
fraîchement élu déjà conspué les
manifestants lancent des avis de
recherche pour rendre compte à la
démocratie et pourquoi rendront compte à
la démocratie peur d'un nouveau refus du
pain il faut dire qu'en france le débat
secoue les familles politiques les
parlementaires le se divisent plupart
couleurs mais par hochement de tête
les oui ouistes on fasse au nonistes
dans un mauvais remake du débat sur la
constitution européenne de 2005
alors ce traité déni de démocratie
alors nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
catherine trautmann bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la présidente de la délégation
socialiste ici au parlement européen bon
il aurait fallu selon vous un référendum
sur ce traité un référendum certainement
pas personne ne considère ici au
parlement européen que ce traité était
nécessaire nous avons voté des
règlements qui stipule pratiquement la
même chose il faut se souvenir que nous
avons une majorité conservatrice et
libérale et que par conséquent la seule
réponse qui était à porter qui se
retrouvent aussi bien dans les textes en
vigueur dans le droit communautaire que
dans ce traité intergouvernemental donc
internationale ce qui fait la différence
avec le traité constitutionnel
tout ceci se trouvant déjà déjà en
vigueur
ce traité était inutile mais l'élu
terrible gifle ratifié quand même qu'il
faut ratifier pour avoir d'abord la
possibilité d'accéder au mécanisme
européen de stabilité
la france si elle ne ratifiez pas se
trouverait dans une situation où elles
n'appliquerait pas évidemment ce traité
y compris le traité sur le mécanisme
européen qui supposerait qu'elles
financent son pouvoir bénéficier de ce
qu'elle aurait financé ce qui serait
tout à fait aberrant c'est nécessaire de
le faire pour être à l'unisson des pays
membres de la zone euro qui veulent
sortir de la crise de l'euro c'est
nécessaire aussi parce que françois
hollande a été très clair dans la
campagne et je pense qu'il faut le
rappeler il a dit je renégocierait ce
traité ce traité ce traité a été un
instrument de renégociation c'est en
même temps une renégociation qui est un
processus c'est le processus de
réorientation de la politique européenne
qui fait qu' il y à ce pacte de
croissance certains disent le compte n'y
est pas on était dans une situation
avant discussions sur le budget c'est
normal que l'on n'ait pas pu aller
jusqu'au bout c'est cette phase si
maintenant où je souhaite et j'espère
que françois hollande ne va pas être
fragile
et dans sa majorité pour pouvoir gagner
le bras fer dans un conseil où il n'est
pas non plus majoritaire est ce que
françois hollande est franchie fragilise
également en europe qu'est ce que vous
disent j'en veux dire aux camarades
députés européens étrangers et ce qu'ils
vous disent ça y est la france est
reparti comme en 2005 mais mes collègues
mais aussi les gouvernements d'autres
pays que je rencontre y compris des
gouvernements conservateurs attendent de
la france qu'elles tiennent bon et du
président de la république une tiennent
bon françois hollande a ouvert un espace
politique pour une volonté politique
pour pouvoir reprendre la maîtrise des
choses à la fois par rapport à leur
respect de la règle ça tranche avec
nicolas sarkozy nicolas sarkozy était
fermement à goûter sur une règle d'or
qui voulait inscrire dans la
constitution
alors qu'il a passé son temps à ne pas
la respecter il aurait pu commencer par
respecter ce qui était déjà inscrit dans
nos règlements il y a des règles
communes pour garder la stabilité de
l'euro donc je crois que il y à cette
attente
cet intérêt que beaucoup de pays accorde
à la position française pourquoi
si on veut résoudre la crise de la dette
il faut des mécanismes pour permettre
aux états de faire face il faut
évidemment réduire cette date
cela suppose des efforts mais c'est des
sports doivent être justes et
supportables pour les populations
et enfin il faut rentrer de nouvelles
recettes si on n'a pas de nouvelles
recettes
on peut pas rembourser dernière question
sur sur ce sujet si jamais françois
hollande avait besoin des voix de la
droite pour que ce traité soit ratifié
par la france
comment ça serait vécue ici en fait ici
au parlement européen ce que l'on craint
c'est qu'effectivement la france se
prennent les pieds dans le tapis d'un
mauvais débat on pense que ce traité
n'en vaut pas la peine
il fait suite à 17 sommet de la dernière
chance donc on connaît la valeur de ce
traité on sait aussi qu'en 2017 on devra
évaluer son impact son efficacité donc
aujourd'hui si vous voulez ce qui est
attendu c'est que les français se
comportent de manière responsable et
soutiennent le président de la
république dans la démarche qu'il a
entreprise parce que tout le monde a
besoin de la france c'est le deuxième
pays contributeur où tout le monde a
besoin aussi de notre contribution
politique
on l'attend sur la pac on l'attend sur
les fonds de cohésion on l'attend sur la
recherche et sur la communauté
européenne de l'énergie
voilà des sujets qui sont très tangible
qui intéresse les français c'est ça à
quoi il faut s'attarder maintenant et se
préoccuper de alors de lancer cette
crise dont on parle actuellement tous
les deux certains ont une solution
ils disent qu'il faut plus d'europe
qu'il faut un saut fédéral alors cette
semaine guy verhofstadt et daniel cohn
bendit qui sont deux ténors ici du
parlement européen ont écrit un
manifeste
il s'appelle debout l'europe je vous
propose qu'on les écoute et ensuite je
vous demanderai votre réaction
on les écoute si nous voulons sortir de
cette crise il faut aller vers une
europe fédérale c'est à dire les
états-nations tels qu'ils existent ne
peuvent pas répondre à la crise
financière économique écologique que
nous vivons au crise que nous vivons
voilà le message très simple et un
deuxième message dans trente ans plus
tôt n'ai aucun état européen ni
l'allemagne ni la france ne fera pas
partie du g8
donc si nous voulons regagner de la
souveraineté ne largue à nyon par
l'europe
sinon c'est les marchés quand une
souveraineté sur nous le chef d'état et
de gouvernement pense qu'en se voyant
quatre fois ou six fois par an ils
peuvent gérer l'europe et sauver l'euro
et ça c'est impossible il faut une vraie
démocratie européenne
un gouvernement européen un marché
obligataire européen
la défense européenne donc il faut tous
les atouts d'un vrai état fédéral c'est
pourquoi moi j'utilise les états unis de
l'europe comme le rêve et le pas qu'il
faut faire maintenant
alors les états unis d'europe
catherine trautmann c'est une belle
utopie c'est possible depuis victor hugo
on sait que c'est un idéal je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la vôtre c'est le mien je
pense qu'il faut je suis plus prudent
sans doute dans l'affirmation parce que
je sais ce qu'attendent les gens les
gens qui aujourd'hui craignent pour leur
épargne pour l'emploi pour leur santé et
la protection sociale ce qui va le cd
résultat le rap de l'efficacité c'est le
rap des politiques et l'évolution
institutionnelle passe par deux choses
la nécessité de renforcer la
coordination des parlements parlements
nationaux au parlement européen nous
sommes élus du peuple nous avons une
légitimité à préserver et nous devons
construire une souveraineté partagée et
deuxièmement nous devons donner plus de
légitimité à la commission car
aujourd'hui c'est là que le bât blesse
avec un président de la commission
qu'ils soient désignés après victoire
d'une indiquant aux élections futures
aux élections européennes voilà qui
serait déjà un grand progrès mais donner
un objectif un cap permet de mesurer
aujourd'hui l'inefficacité de cette
sorte de restriction de réserve de
résistance à la construction européenne
nous états membres et nos gouvernements
doivent faire preuve de courage
politique pour avancer sur ce picto cui
à l'europe fédérale mais procédons par
étape
procédons par étape ayons d'abord des
résultats au niveau des politiques ça
commence par la vérification de la façon
dont on sortira de la négociation
budgétaire
catherine trautmann merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation va
continuer de parler d'argent en europe
et en particulier en france puisque
jean-marc ayrault a présenté cette
semaine
ce qu'il a appelé son budget de combat
pour 2013 et nous avons fait un zapping
des télévisions européennes il est signé
aurélie d'afas regarder
ils n'en veulent pas peu importe son nom
dscg ou pactes budgétaire pour les
manifestants parisiens ce traité est
synonyme d'austérité il le chante le
hurle l'écrit l'austérité il entasse et
c'est la première manifestation
d'importance pour les forces s'affichant
résolument à la gauche du parti
socialiste
la colère monte de la rue car
l'austérité est déjà là avec le budget
de combat dévoilé par jean marc ayrault
la france a pris ce soir les détails
d'un des budgets les plus rigoureux
depuis 30 ans les ministres se sont
réunis à l'elysée pour trouver un moyen
de renflouer les finances du pays et de
réduire les déficits le gouvernement a
été clair que les ménages les plus
riches et les plus grandes entreprises
devront consentir aux plus grosses
conséquences de cette annonce pour la
télévision italienne
une consommation en berne et des
mécontents surtout à droite
l'austérité pourrait faire chuter la
consommation alors que la majorité
socialiste a basé tous ces calculs sur
l'espoir que l'année prochaine la france
n'entre pas en récession
dans ce cas la conséquence inévitable
serait plus de taxes mais déjà un
journal de droite titre c'est trop
alors nous avons été rejoints par
raymond l'oeuvre bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le correspondant permanent ici à
bruxelles de la télévision autrichienne
le f
comment est vu je dirais de bruxelles
pour commencer ce budget de combat est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui
impressionne ou est ce qu'on dit
finalement la france ne fait que
rattraper son retard
je crois qu en europe en général on ne
suit pas les détails des discussions
budgétaires dans les différents pays ce
qui a attiré le plus d'attention ce le
fait que daniel cohn bendit que quand
même un politicien de renommée européens
à quitter le parti vert en france parce
qu'il n'était pas d'accord avec la ligne
sur l'europe
il a été suivi les discussions sur le
budget aussi nous dans le temps leurs
rêves
bien sûr notre reporter de paris on a
parlé mais c'est pas un grand sujet ce
qui est un sujet plus grand c'est qu'on
n'a pas une très bonne idée ce que la
france veut en europe
en europe il ya des grandes discussions
en allemagne aux pays bas
quel est le chemin que l'europe doit
prendre et la france
et là elle existe mais c'est tout ce
qu'on peut dire il ya peut-être des
détails dans les orientations européen
ou
la france à faire de petits faits de
petit changement mais dans les grands
débats
je prends la france on n'a pas vraiment
le poids que beaucoup attente elle
devrait pas bon ça c'est nouveau vous
disiez que sa date de l'élection de
françois hollande où c'était déjà le cas
sous nicolas sarkozy
bon avant il y avait mercredi c'est lé
duo français allemands qui n'étaient pas
très apprécié souvent c'est mais qui
existait maintenant la question c'est
est ce qu'il ya un pilote dans l'avion
parce que évidemment le duo franco
allemand n'existe plus la france semble
s'allier avec les pays du sud à certains
moments en même temps maintient
évidemment les relations très importante
avec l'allemagne mais c'est une
situation plus floue comment et vu la
relation un peu difficile un peu
délicate qui existent justement entre
françois hollande et en gala merkel
c'est très contradictoire parce qu'on
al'impression ce sont deux personnalités
qui se ressemblent ce sont des personnes
très pragmatique
ce sont des personnages qui ont l'air de
réfléchir avant qu'il dise quelque chose
mais en même temps les discussions
politiques les orientations politiques
divergent ça il n'a pas l'impression que
jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant que des deux
côtés on a réussi à se mettre d'accord
regardez en allemagne il y a une
sérieuse discussion est ce que on a
besoin des états unis de l'europe
oui ou non aux pays bas on a eu une
discussion semblable ça a même décidé
des élections cette discussion a en
france n'existe pas et ça on le sent en
europe l'europe est dans la rue en
france d'une certaine façon avec une
manifestation là qui a eu lieu récemment
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment est ce
qu'on a le sentiment vue d'autriche ou
peut-être de bruxelles que finalement la
france est en train de revivre un peu ce
qui s'est passé en 2005 avec le non au
référendum
on se pose la question je crois pas que
on a l'impression que c'est décidé mais
il ya un contradiction que dans les rues
des pays du sud
il a beaucoup d émotion il ya beaucoup
de slogans sur la justice la nécessité
de la protection sociale
mais il y a très peu d'idées qu'est ce
qu'on doit vraiment faire un autre
nouveau parce que c'est facile d'être
dans la rue de dire non je suis quoi on
est contre l'austérité
mais c'est beaucoup plus difficile au
niveau européen d'avoir un plan qui met
ensemble des pays du nord et les pays du
sud
et ça c'est le danger qu'il ya un
clivage entre nord et sud et de la gtoi
la france sert le meilleur placé pour
faire un pont pour éviter que cette
vache devient plus profonde
raymond love merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation leur va rester
sur un sujet européen où chaque pays a
une position différente je parle du
sujet de la drogue et la façon qu'on a
d'aider les drogués alors il existe dans
un certain nombre de pays
ce qu'on appelle des salles de shoot le
gouvernement français a d'ailleurs
peut-être décidé en tout cas il
réfléchit en créant francs si nous avons
été voir avec jérôme rabier au
luxembourg comment ça se passait et
ensuite on retrouve germain andrieu
et son invité coincé entre une entrée
d'autoroute et les voies de chemin de
fer c'est ici dans ces préfabriqués que
les toxicomanes viennent trouver un
refuge un abri un lieu pour se droguer
installé en 2005 à quelques centaines de
mètres de la gare
c'est l'unique salle de consommation du
pays à l'intérieur une équipe
d'éducateurs et du personnel médical
accueille les usagers
cent vingt par jour en moyenne ici on ne
fournit que le matériel nécessaire à la
prise de drogue
le produit en grande majorité de
l'héroïne est apportée par le client il
a ensuite vingt minutes pour le
consommer et la structure ne désemplit
pas ils sont près de mille deux cents
toxicomanes à y être inscrits pour y
accéder il faut signer un contrat où
l'on accepte les règles du lieu pas de
deal pas de bagarre et le respect pour
le personnel comme pour les locaux
philippe est un usager régulier
rien que dans cette matinée cet accro à
l'héroïne depuis 25 ans passera trois
fois dans la salle de consommation
l'héroïne ch la fume donc voilà j'ai mon
endroit tranquille
kim assure une sécurité j'ai pas besoin
de le faire dans des endroits cachés
mais qu'est ce que vous répondez aux
gens qui disent que ici ça facilite
ma drogue ce que j'ai fait j'en aurais
vu une personne qui va ce progrès que ça
soit ici ou ailleurs elle le fera c'est
pas parce que voilà c'est un endroit où
tous les toxicomanes se rencontrent que
ça va accentuer encore plus les
problèmes au contraire si le lieu est
médiatisé pour sa salle de shoot c'est
une structure plus large qui est proposé
doté d'un budget annuel de plus de 2
millions d'euros on y vient aussi pour
juste prendre un café échangé ses
seringues usagées trouver de l'aide pour
ses démarches administratives 42 lits
sont aussi disponibles la nuit pour
héberger les toxicomanes sans abri le
centre et la prise en charge et
personnes ce n'est pas simplement leur
donner un endroit où ils peuvent
consommer comme ils veulent
beaucoup de gens ont rempli avec leurs
familles ont rompu avec la société
parfois et il est important je pense
pour un pays de garder le contact avec
les personnes très vulnérables souvent
malades qui ont besoin des aides et
qu'on peut pas laisser
la montée il ya sept ans la structure
s'est pérennisée à l'époque dans ce
quartier habitué aux toxicomanes les
riverains étaient réticents le temps a
finalement permis l'acceptation du
projet c'est consommer demande devant
une école primaire où ils s
on la peau voilà je sais pas s'ils le
font toujours mais les instituteurs ils
venaient plus tôt pour faire le tour
pour ramasser des seringues avant que
les enfants arrivaient du quartier
peut-être que quelques résistances oui
bien sûr il ya toujours beaucoup de gens
qui sont résistants qui voilà qu'ils
veulent qu'ils préfèrent que ce soit un
quartier à côté
car derrière l'objectif sanitaire c'est
aussi la question de la sécurité qui est
en jeu ouvert 6 jours sur 7
le centre permet de maintenir la
population toxicomane à distance
respectable du centre ville un objectif
assumé par la mairie en effet que c'est
une sécurité et pour la population de la
ville de luxembourg qui a tort ou à
raison à ce sentiment d'insécurité par
rapport aux personnes toxicomanes mais
c'est aussi une sécurité pour les
personnes concernées bien entendu il y a
un deal qui se fait tout autour nous le
savons nous ne pouvons pas l'éviter
on pourrait peut-être dire donc on peut
mieux le contrôler puisqu'elle les a
cédées limitée dans les sports oms et
ans d'existence les résultats en matière
de santé publique sont là le nombre
d'overdoses a été divisé par quatre et
les contaminations sont en chute libre
la mairie cherche désormais un terrain
pour accueillir une structure définitive
et une deuxième salle de consommation
doit ouvrir d'ici peu dans la deuxième
ville du pays à moins de cinq kilomètres
de la frontière française
voilà c'était un reportage de jérôme
rabier avec thomas l'os nous a rejoints
sur ce plateau sophie auconie bonjour
alors vous êtes membre du ppe oeuvre
également membre de la commission de
l'environnement et la santé publique et
pour que les choses soient claires vous
appartenez en france à lui d y avec jean
louis borloo de ne pas du côté de l'ump
on vous a vu pendant ce reportage était
assez dubitative
vous êtes opposé à ces salles de shoot
c'est une question de principe alors je
ne suis pas opposé aux salles de shoot
pour moi il y a deux types
d'établissements un établissement comme
celui qu'on vous convient de voir qui
est plus qu'une salle de shoot c'est un
établissement de soins finalement
d'accueil qui est ouvert six jours sur
sept et 24 heures sur 24 pendant les six
jours d'ouverture tout d'abord pour moi
ce type d'établissement doit être ouvert
7 jours sur 7
parce que les héroïnomanes n'arrête pas
de se piquer le dimanche
donc je me dis que la salle de shoot
ouvertes 4 5 heures dans la journée et
qui n'a pas d'autre objectif que de
participer enfin de faire en sorte qu'on
offre un lieu pour les héros mais aurait
héroïnomane pour se piquer n'est pas
suffisant et que c'est un petit moyen
qui ne correspond pas aux besoins de ces
drogués
alors effectivement mais c'est souvent
le cas ce sont souvent des structures
sociales dans lesquelles s'intègrent ces
salles de shoot en france est un vieux
serpent de mer depuis 40 ans à la gauche
et à droite se rejettent le sujet est ce
que c'est une question de santé publique
ou une question criminalité moi je
regarde ça sous l'angle de la santé
publique
quand je vois 15 centres de soins au
delà la salle de shoot un centre de
soins coûtent aujourd'hui 2 millions
d'euros moi je me pose la question
2 millions d'euros c'est deux millions
d'euros doivent aujourd'hui servir à
soutenir les personnes droguées à aller
dans le sens de supprimer leurs
addictions il faut que nous les soignons
que nous que nous les aidions à se
soigner
à titre personnel à titre personnel vous
êtes opposés à la création de salles de
shoot en france ou pas je suis le débat
était lancé par jean marie le guen
le député ps de paris qui lui même est
médecin est ce que c'est il ya une
urgence sanitaire aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas pour la salle de shoot dans deux
quartiers qui va accueillir de 10 heures
à 15 heures des héroïnomanes
pour moi c'est ça n'est pas on ne va pas
dans la prévention
on ne va pas dans le mythique santé
publique on est plus sur l'outil
peut-être sécuritaire effectivement et
je souhaiterais mois qu'on donne à ce
projet une dimension de santé publique
en se donnant les moyens à l'image de ce
qu'a fait luxembourg mais en allant
encore plus loin
mais comment appréhender ce type de
population aujourd'hui n'est pas
possible de les mettre avec les autres
sans abri c'est une copulation spéciale
il faut les approcher comment faire ce
premier contact il ya exactement comme
l'a fait le luxembourg c'est à dire
organiser un centre de soins les
services sociaux des mairies connaissent
savent où aller les voir où aller leur
présenter ce cette nouvelle offre de
santé publique et c'est de cet
hébergement pour les soins mais je pense
qu'au delà de leur offrir
on a vu des choses difficiles un ces
personnes qui viennent à la chaîne qui
prennent qui signe un contrat qui
prennent les seringue les petites
cuillères qui vont faire leurs shoots et
puis qui repartent souffre que d'un
point de vue du soutien en tant que tel
à ces personnes c'est un peu juste
pourtant il ya des faits en termes de
salubrité publique on voit les overdoses
ont été divisées par quatre dans ce
centre et il ya également une chute
vertigineuse des contaminations a que
cela soit pour les hépatites ou pour le
sida et c'est le cas dans tous les
centres qui ont été créés en europe
est-ce que du point de vue la salubrité
publique ça marche oui je pense que ça
marche c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous dis qu'il faut aller plus loin que
ça est ce que je voudrais vous dire
c'est que en france par exemple
mais en europe en général le nombre de
consommateurs de drogues dures à l'image
de
dr de l'héroïne et en étant est en
baisse or en france nous n'avons pas de
salles de shoot
donc je pense que la prévention le soin
l'accueil et le soutien de ces personnes
droguées de ces héroïnomane et le led à
aller vers la suppression de cette
addiction
et la meilleure façon de travailler avec
eux de vrais pour eux traditionnellement
entre la droite et la gauche en france
il y à une opposition entre la
prévention et l'encadrement de ce type
de population vous seriez pour une
solution un peu médiane justement de
faire les deux à la fois c'est bien ça
exactement vous savez moi je porte les
valeurs des du progrès sociétal
donc je souhaite que j'ai quatre enfants
donc je sais que je suis sensibilisé à
ce problème et je souhaite qu'on aille
dans le sens de les soutenir et d'aller
plus loin que l'encadrement ou que
l'accueil pure et simple je souhaite
qu'on les aide à aller au delà de ça et
moi si j'ai deux mains un enfant
vraiment kiki qui étaient dans cette
situation je souhaiterais qu'il souhaite
accompagner plus que encadré pour faire
ce qu'il a à faire
voyez ce que je veux dire alors vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure il ya tout de
même une question de coût on est sur
deux millions d'euros 1 pour budget
annuel pour le centre qu'on a vu dans ce
dans ce reportage
il ya 90 centres dans le monde plus de
80 en europe et on le sait l'espagne a
dû fermer plusieurs centres pour des
questions financières et ce qu'en pleine
crise économique
on peut mener de front une telle
politique et je pense qu'il faut faire
un calcul simple combien coûte à la
société
toutes ces personnes qui sont pour
certaines malades dans le cas de la
transmission du vih vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure qui souffre d'un certain
nombre d'overdoses qui vont jusqu'à la
mort parfois donc combien coûte cette ce
problème de santé publique en france et
donc que doit-on mettre en face pour
pour quel résultat je crois que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut que
nous regardions j'imagine que le
gouvernement a regardé ça j'ai vu que
marisol touraine s'était positionné en
faveur donc c'est qu'elle a dû faire
également ce type de quelques jeux on ne
peut plus partir sur des
et pensons sans regarder les
conséquences positives à court terme
alors quand on fait un petit peu le
point en europe plusieurs pays
expérimentent déjà ces salles de shoot
il ya entre autres la suisse qui est le
précurseur l'espagne l'allemagne ou
encore les pays-bas le prochain pays
devrait être le danemark vous souhaité
que la france soit en pointe sur ce
sujet très lisse oui c'est à dire que je
ne vous le redis je souhaite qu'on aille
au delà messages images et structures
une structure sociale qui permettent la
voilà vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure on
ne peut pas mélanger une population sans
domicile fixe une population difficultés
liées à l'alcool il peut plier voilà les
héroïnomanes les personnes qui sont
addicts décès de drogues dures mérite un
traitement spécifique
et puis la société mérite effectivement
d'être sécurisée par rapport aux serein
qu'on peut trouver dans des dents des
bois dans des dans des parkings dans des
endroits c'est vrai je suis d'accord
mais je ne souhaite pas que l'état soit
le dealer finalement de cette activité
je souhaite qu'elle aille bien nolan au
delà de ça le haut niveau européen on
peut l'imaginer coopération a en tout
cas c'est l'objectif de qui n'a pas
forcément cette compétence mais qui
souhaitent envoyer comme signale
effectivement une coopération entre les
états notamment pour lutter contre le
commerce illégal de la drogue oui bien
sûr je pense que c'est important
eh bien merci sophy le clean d'avoir été
avec nous dans l'europe est au rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro très bonne sur des
programmes et à très bientôt sur les
chaînes parlementaires